do you love odd one out
did you know that every purchase at the
jubilee shop helps fund this show
if you're looking for ways to support
jubilee and watch more episodes of odd
one out make sure you check out our
merch at shop.jubileemedia.com
now enjoy this episode
she does this weird howling thing
i'm gonna do it
i swear
we brought together seven dog owners i'm
a dog owner i am a dog owner i'm a dog
owner i am a dog owner i'm a dog owner
i'm a dog owner i'm a dog owner
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
so my name is roy and this is jessica
i'm diana this is bella i'm sherman this
is ollie vanessa and this is tank i'm
okie and this is sasha i'm abigail and
this is keikoa i'm trish and this is
hiro have you guys always been dog
owners yes this is actually my first
time did you not like dogs before i did
i did but i mean you know school and
whatnot i'm a first time dog owner first
time dog owner yeah my girlfriend and i
we can't she can't have kids
biologically so
so this is our baby and she gets all the
spoilage i grew up with dogs my whole
life did you know that he was deaf
before you got him no it was kind of
like a drug deal and then they found out
later that he was deaf if you're gonna
fake it you're not gonna bring a deaf
dog or a dog with a handicap so i
thought that was pretty legit i had a
problem before keto but i feel like this
is well my first dog as an adult so it's
definitely a different experience this
time around yeah
how about we name like
our favorite dog
[Music]
she just seemed a little bit quiet
he was so attentive to the dog that i
was like maybe he has to be that
attentive because it isn't his dog
trish was a little suspicious because
she just wasn't really interacting with
her dog at all
we have a tie
the tie is between
trish
abigail and vanessa marie
each of you is going to get 20 seconds
to state your case okay my name is
vanessa this is my dog tank i've had him
for about five years he does have an
instagram tanks a movie if you guys want
to follow him
i love him so much he's my best friend i
don't know what i will do without him
when he does go on but
obviously this is keikoa i decided to
bring him out of all my dogs because he
is the best trained i can show you some
hand signals if that helps nicole
no okay
um
i just have a lot of dogs and i promise
i am a dog owner a hundred percent all
right i'm trish this is hiro spelled
h-i-r-o i actually have his name
engraved on this necklace a lot of
people like have never seen corey's
before i guess and they'll like be super
excited and they'll be like oh this
totally brightened my day so i think
it's really awesome to have a pup that
also makes other people happy as well as
myself so
i think i like felt a little stiff and
maybe that made everyone think i wasn't
interacting enough with my dog this will
be the dog tricks round sit
right
paw
down
good job
come on
give me the other one other one good boy
down good boy pull over roll over
she does this weird halloween thing
i'm gonna do it
[Applause]
actually
yeah good job buddy
touch high five good job i actually
thought sherman was suspicious because
his dog was like a little too good and
he just seemed very professional with
the way he was handling it thought maybe
he was a trainer sasha sit
down
yeah oh
she wants
praise belly
[Music]
he was more lacks with his dog i thought
maybe he's not a real dog owner
[Music]
we have a tie
between
sherman and okie i knew all these tricks
we had this chemistry like me and ollie
and i thought that would be like okay
he's good like he's not the fake each
one will get 20 seconds to state your
case all right well i am the real dog
owner um he knew all those tricks when
he was a kid because you know you can't
take him out after all their shots so i
taught him all the tricks just to
mentally stimulate him see my favorite
memory of him because i know you said
earlier um it's probably just him
learning how to go up and down the
stairs was like the cutest thing when he
was a little puppy sasha is my baby i do
own her saved her from vietnam or taiwan
and that's what uh made it so hard for
her tricks she just
doesn't really
take very well to training we actually
send her away to boot camp to train her
because she was aggressive towards other
dogs this right here is just a miracle
that she's even able to do this
[Music]
hi
guys i was disappointed because i'm a
pretty competitive person and i really
thought i was gonna win
please raise your hand if you still have
doubt and want to continue playing the
game in three
two one
i wasn't looking for a dog i was on
facebook marketplace and then i saw her
on there for like 100 bucks i went all
the way riverside and then she just
started like hitting me and then like
running so i was like i was like oh is
this happiness dude huskies
what do you guys feed them it's like in
the pastel blue bag i think thanks to
the buffalo yeah blue buffalo i used to
feed them that but now they get purina
chicken blend mix and it gets with like
another fancy brand she
didn't know what kind of brand of food
very well at first so i was kind of a
little suspicious about that every
morning i cook him boiled chicken
because he did get sick at some point
people think he's spoiled but um what's
your guys's like favorite dog movie like
mine as a kid was airbud i actually
don't really like dog movies i like
marley and me but i can tell you which
one i don't like i don't like hachi
because it like breaks my heart what do
you think is the most special thing
about your dog she's just really
friendly with anyone for me it's mainly
been the support that she's been like
the emotional support i think mine is a
he's a cuddler before bed
so he just i mean i don't train him i
used to but not anymore well for me my
dog is very metal
he's like
ever since he was a puppy he was never
hyperactive my favorite thing is how
accepting he is of every single dog and
human he needs he's such a good boy
[Music]
he just seemed really really nervous
she just gave me the vibe that she was a
trainer
oh goodbye guys
bye ollie
okay okay okay
please raise your hand if you still have
doubt that you caught the mole and want
to continue playing the game continue
playing yes
i just have like one quick question um
so vaccination records like what
vaccines do you currently have on all
your dogs like with mine i have parvo
distemper which is dhvp and then i have
rabies we have the parvo and the rabies
he has the rabies and
i don't know the exact name because i've
never worked with dogs before i honestly
don't know them off the top of my memory
that's not because i'm not a dog owner i
also feel like maybe you know playing
the other side of the car knowing the
exact vaccines but you you know dogs so
that could be why but also it could be
suspicion someone who was extremely
knowledgeable about dogs like who it
seems like they'd studied about it then
maybe they were the mole do you train
dogs i actually i don't train i mean i
train my dogs but i don't train dogs i
just i'm so comfortable dogs so since
someone was deaf do you have to like
do like special classes in order to
learn how to communicate no actually my
boyfriend did the majority of the
training for him specifically and then
after that when he he taught me
everything so he can respond like if you
tap him to look at you except he doesn't
want he's mad right now so is he legally
like under your name or your boyfriend
boyfriends
yeah okay maybe it's
she's not a dog owner at all and she's
just bringing her friend's dog and then
i had a question for you you said you
didn't work with dogs but earlier you
said you were like a vet vet assistant
so well i'm a manager at a veterinarian
clinic but i used to be a vet assistant
but for cats i do take my dog to her
because she seats dogs at another clinic
but
i felt like she was trying very hard to
be a dog owner so that kind of made me
think like i think she might be a mole
oh
that's weird okay
please raise your hand if you still have
doubt that you caught the mole and want
to continue playing the game in three
two one
the only reason i wanted to continue
because he said he was your boyfriend
but how does but still like dog owner
he's still
yeah i know i realized that could be
kids biggest but i am because i am a dog
owner it still i just chose to bring him
specifically so if i had brought like
another one of my dogs it still would
have been the same kind of term where
it's still like dog have any of you guys
had any experience where uh like you
know it was an emergency that you had to
take your pet to the hospital i had a
bigger pitbull before he died away he
passed away and have my smaller
chihuahua and they were outside and he
like bit him so i had to take him to the
bed like late and
maybe she's a trainer you know maybe
like this is professional like she does
this
we were so close we thought we were
gonna win it i was sad but i was fine
you know i was really proud of how far
we made it if the lights turn green that
means you have voted out the mall and
you win if the light turns red that
means the mole is still in the box and
you lose
will the fake dog owner please step
forward and reveal yourself in three
two
one
[Music]
everything is actually true she really
is from taiwan we really did center away
training but it's my brother's dog and i
dog sit for him all the time so i spent
a ton of time with her and she is really
sweet i do want a dog of my own but
right now i live in a very tiny
one-bedroom apartment i can't really get
the kind of dog i want and give it the
life that it deserves i don't think it's
for everyone it's a lot of work and i
think a lot of people think it's a walk
in the park they give you a different
kind of love it's unconditional love
that not everyone can give you if i have
a hard day knowing i'm going home to
some dog that really loves you so much i
think that's like the best thing in the
world dogs are just the best thing in
the world can i make it rain on your dog
yeah
your teeth
look i totally worn
she was like mom
no
[Music]